- I do a lot of training
for many corporations,
and I conduct sales
seminars and I've heard
all kind of guys doing
techniques and training,
people techniques of how to close sales,
and how to work with them and
begin to control the sale,
and how to ask for the close.
Let me share something with you.
You can learn all the
techniques in the world.
If you don't believe in yourself,
it won't happen for you.
I learned all of it.
That's why I do a training
called Focus on the Seller.
You've got to focus on you,
and as you convince you,
as you sell yourself every
day, every day, every day,
you will begin to see a difference
in the things that you're doing.
Selling yourself on your
ability to perform a job,
to achieve a certain objective,
telling yourself every day,
"Here I go again and I got what it takes.
This is my day and nothing
out here is going to stop me."
(triumphant music)